i am looking carefully at the numbers
virtually every day
and i'm saying to myself
i know this new variant is more easily
transmitted
and i know that it can actually
bypass some of the
vaccines that we've all been taking
and i just wonder
how serious is it going to be
for people who are most at risk older
people or people with diabetes or others
who are exposed to a lot of infection
yeah i'm still
really asking everybody
please be super careful over the coming
two or three weeks because
we're not yet at a point where we can
look each other in the eyes and say
we're through the worst of us actually
i think we're just coming into the
toughest part the part when a lot of
people are being infected a lot of
health workers actually are suffering a
lot of people in essential services like
hospitality or travel are getting
infected and we are going to have to
batten down and weather this one in true
human spirit we just don't have any
alternative there's light at the end of
the tunnel but the end of the tunnel is
still some weeks even months away yes dr
jenny harry's talked of a glimmer of
christmas hope didn't she
this morning and it appears from the
data that people are less likely to go
to hospital but most of the people who
are infected are the younger cohorts so
when do you think we will know about how
this impacts older people
well i asked my colleagues in the sort
of center of the world health
organization the people who analyzed the
numbers
and they're saying even though we've got
two or three studies coming through now
that suggests that omicron is not quite
as nasty as the other variants of kovid
they're also saying just be careful
because we just do not yet know how
older people are going to be affected
we also don't have data on how people
who've not been vaccinated are going to
fare and so
please hold on everybody really
do everything you can to minimize
contacts this christmas just try to
avoid having to get up close to a lot of
strangers in the pub or something and
let's focus on next year let's focus on
getting through 2022 getting ahead of
the virus and then
having a really good celebration at the
end of 2022
rather than feeling that we've got to
just do everything possible this year
and then getting into trouble so i'm
going to say please take it carefully
please treat it with respect
2021 was all about the vaccine wasn't it
the development of it the roll out of
the vaccine and everybody hoped that it
would be the game changer it would stop
this in its tracks it's 2022
i mean we're already talking about
potentially giving people a fourth
vaccine now is 2022 going to be about
the other treatments that might come on
stream to really help uh lessen the
effects of kovacs well first of all
we've got some lovely success stories
with these vaccines
wonderful stories of science coming to
the rescue of humanity in a way that
none of us really anticipated even a
year ago
and and we managed to be able to
separate now getting sick from actually
succumbing and dying and that's a really
brilliant situation to be in
unfortunately not everybody is
benefiting from this there's still a
real unevenness in vaccine availability
around the world so my wish for 2022 is
to get vaccines available for everyone
everywhere then we're going to get these
treatments now they're still early
stages and i'm looking very carefully at
the data
we let's not assume that we're going to
be able to treat all the covid that
we're going to have next year we're
going to be able to see some treatments
come on on stream
most importantly the thing that makes
the greatest difference is being careful
about our contacts
wearing our masks makes such a
difference i just wanted to be clear
with everybody i take my mask wearing
seriously i encourage you to do so as
well it's a real sign of respect for
others if you wear your mask
particularly when you're in shops when
you're in hospitality or when you're
social and perhaps the most important
thing i want to say is if you aren't yet
fully vaccinated and boosted please do
your best to get your booster quickly
even if you're hovering with uncertainty
i want to say to you looking you
straight in the eye
get yourself vaccinated it really is
worthwhile and it's also good for others
in your family if you know that you are
protected and having a much less
likelihood of severe illness
message coming over loud and clear on
that david i'm just wondering
final question for you really given the
very high levels of transmission with
omicron is there a chance that
the level of immunity that will result
from the number of infections could be
uh it could be the variant that turns it
from being a pandemic an epidemic into
endemic yes samantha i
really don't like looking ahead and
making predictions but because it's
christmas eve and because i'm here with
you tonight let me just give it a chance
i actually do hope
that this new variant is going to be the
variant that spreads widely that infects
quite a lot of people
that combined with vaccines leads to a
much greater immunity among the human
population i'm also hoping that it's the
beginning of this virus becoming less
virulent we're not there yet and it's
going to be a bumpy ride but let's just
all hope and let's do our best right now
to keep ourselves and our families and
our communities as healthy and safe as
possible and who knows as my colleague
dr ted ross who runs the world health
organization says
let's beat this virus in 2022 it's a
goal that really is worth while to
achieve
yes here here i think everybody watching
will agree with you entirely really
appreciate you taking the leap into the
unknown there for us and also appreciate
your time on christmas eve dr david
nabarro merry christmas thank you thank
you samantha merry christmas to all
viewers thank you